va voir qui joue le mieux du piano c'est
max mais ça faisait mouche oui quoi ça
marche la sonate de chopin
elle va faire une salade de jours par
les esprits me permettre s'il pouvait
mettre votre pied ici pour tenir le truc
ce petit là il va descendre les bras
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
m
j'adorais c'est que je dis c'est quoi
amélie poulain la bo amélie poulain le
chocolat ne sais pas s'étonne quand ça
va tant mieux si si il a dit qu'il
faisait rien est-ce que vous pouvez nous
jouer autre chose pour prouver à tout le
monde à valérie quoi la lettre elle et
s'est retrouvé non non c'est non mais là
naîtra dans un tonnerre j'étais cette
ombre aux abattoirs jouer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gfr
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2009la ses dix ans peut-être tapas cas
pas un truc que bah oui l'ambiance bien
sûr
[Musique]
[Rires]
on
ouais et aux études crois tu te mets qui
s'est cru à mercredi après c'est pas
commencé à jouer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous bonsoir à tous et bienvenue coscia
doo wop
une ambiance musicale ouvert du lundi au
dimanche de 8h à 22h et de 23h à minuit
le cha doo apps ont souvent bien
chaloupés pour les gens qui aiment la
danse et qui aime manger un petit bout
peut pas au coin du bois
ça y est tu ne joues pas le bac est un
peu pompeux pour m arrêter cette merde à
allah
l'animal à l'animal
mais disait tu est excellent ce soir les
lunéa je n'ai jamais vu un cas pareil
mais les chéris s'abat en pleine forme
au milieu ou fin d'été tranquille lui
les faits on peut le dire personne ne
sait bien jouer mais sinon je sais pour
venir parce que des gens parce que dr
house la série joue bien chabal est ce
que vous savez jouer quelque chose des
années 2000 ah non mais je les savais
jouer quoi cette fois gaye une chanson
pour guy elton john c'est magnifique
pour un gars il connaît un morceau qu'on
va tourner quoi du modèle à l'essai nous
appelons les téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
et c'est que les périodes je viens d'air
pour jouer de l'air tu vas en avoir à
partir de septembre
[Musique]
et
je
tu te rends pas compte gouttes en train
de faire chier tout le temps comme ça
elle avoir les oreilles qui saignent
merci quand il était ado pour draguer le
huawei